[Music]
hey everyone welcome back for another
episode
of introducing where i show you all
sorts of
beautiful and rare instruments from the
past
as long as they go pluck so
today we're going to talk about one of
the most important
if not the most important instrument of
the musical period we call
the renaissance and that is the loot
now you might actually be familiar with
this instrument a little bit already
you might have seen it in paintings at
museums
or even in video games like skyrim
or you know netflix series like the
witcher
everybody wants me to cover songs from
the witcher now
but the renaissance loot has a really
fascinating
history and we're going to learn all
about it today now this episode of
introducing was actually made in
collaboration
with a company called tonebase and if
you don't know about tonebase they're a
really fantastic website
that offers lessons and tutorials
that are really well done from some of
the world's finest
guitar players so i'd really encourage
you to check that out
but for now let's learn about the
renaissance loot
[Music]
the loot was one of the most important
instruments of the renaissance
which took place roughly between the
14th to early 17th
centuries it was used in shakespeare's
plays
kings and queens adored its magical
sound
every day people played it on street
corners and in pubs
and even galileo's father vincenzo
galilei
played the loot because of the loot's
ability to play polyphony
meaning several independent moving
voices it was considered the ideal
solo instrument as well as an ideal
instrument for accompanying
the voice now the loot
is a likely descendant of the ud
this instrument arrived in europe likely
in the 8th century when the
moors conquered the iberian peninsula
and oods are usually teardrop shaped or
pear-shaped
they have round backs bow backs
long necks and friction pegs so
each peg is kind of like a violin you
just have to push and turn
to get it to stay um they were played
with
plectrums probably something like a
quill uh an eagles
feather or other materials
each string was doubled
and they were fretless so you can play
a variety of notes in between the sort
of western 12
tone system
[Music]
over time europeans adapted
the ood to meet their own musical needs
and they kept
basically the same shape teardrop shape
ball back
bend backward neck friction pegs all
that but
they ended up adding frets and
for those frets they used the same
material as the strings
which were made of at the time gut so
sheep intestine
and that's what we we have here this is
uh these are sheep intestine gut frets
which are just tied around and are
movable
now it seems that by the time we get to
the 14th century
the europeans had a loot which generally
had
four pairs of strings and then in the
15th century they added a
fifth and by the time we get to the 16th
century
six coarse loots were common that's six
pairs
of strings for hundreds of years in the
medieval period
lutonis still played with a plectrum
just like
food players but in the late 15th
century
they began dropping the pick in favor of
using
the fingertips to pluck and the
advantage of that new technique
is that you can play several independent
voices simultaneously two three or even
four parts
at the same time this is what we call
polyphony
and with this new technique the golden
age of the loot began
and during this golden age the loot was
considered one of the most
loved instruments throughout europe for
over 150 years
now as i mentioned in the early 16th
century six chorus loots
were common but as we get closer to the
end of the 16th century
people began experimenting with adding
more and more bass strings to increase
the bass range of the instrument so you
start seeing loots with
an extra seventh string then an extra
eighth string
nine and even ten courses in the
renaissance
this loot here is an eight course it has
eight pairs of strings
in terms of the technique of playing the
loot the left hand is rather similar to
a
modern guitar it's pretty much the same
[Music]
same uh but the right hand is where
things get
uh really interesting uh as i mentioned
before
lutonis played with a plectrum for
hundreds of years
and they did so by holding the loot more
horizontally and wrapping their arm
around the bottom of the loop like this
they put their pinky down on the top and
move from the arm to play up and down
with the pick which is not too far away
from what electric guitar players
do today but when they dropped the pick
when they abandoned the pick
for playing with the fingers they
retained this position
so pinky down and they moved the arm
and instead of playing down and up with
a pick they began playing down
the thumb and up with the index finger
so you get this
really nice strong weak strong weak
sound
by using those fingers and moving from
the arm rather than just
the fingers lutonists in the early 16th
century developed this thumb and index
alternation
technique to such a high level
writing some of the most beautifully
virtuosic music
playing rapid scales up and down the
instrument
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
now this thumb under alternation
technique uh was used a lot in the early
16th century
but as we get later and later and add
more bases to the loot it seems that
loot players went from this sort of
playing position which we call thumb
under
and gradually morphed into this
playing position which we call thumb out
and you can see it in so many paintings
especially in the early 17th century
loot players played still with their
pinky down but with the thumb
rather to the left of the fingers and
they did this to accommodate
the low bass strings when it comes to
the tuning
loots are actually not so distant from
the tuning of modern guitars
they're mostly tuned in fourths with one
major third
and for solo loots they seem to have
generally been tuned
to uh g or a meaning that so for example
if you had a loot in g
like this one you would get on a six
course loot
g c f a d
g now if you have perfect pitch
or you're checking out a tuner you might
notice that the notes that i just said
don't match with a
piano or maybe even your tuner and
that's because we have to remember that
pitch in the renaissance was relative
there was no
absolute a equals 440 hertz
this is a more modern idea so
basically bigger loots were tuned lower
and smaller loots were tuned
higher in fact there's even a quote from
a treatise that says
take your high string the first string
tune it as high as it can go
before breaking stop then tune the rest
of the instrument proportionally
to that and whatever you get to on the
top you might just call
g but to our modern ears that g could be
a whole step
lower or maybe even a half step higher
currently my g is a whole step lower
than the modern
g and you'll see that just like the ood
each string is doubled
so i have two of each note except for
the very first string
so the first string was called the
chantorel which means the singing string
it was often
single every other course every other
string is doubled
um the higher strings tend to be more in
tuned in unisons
and as we get deeper in the bass range
often you would find that there be one
thick gut string
tuned to the low note in this case c but
they be reinforced with a higher octave
so they sound simultaneously as one
pitch
but actually i'm hearing two
distinct notes and that will just go on
for the all the bases
[Music]
now the notation for this instrument is
actually very clever
it's tablature which guitarists today
know tablature very well and they
consider it sort of
the easiest way of learning the
instrument and luton is not the same
it is very intuitive very clever and in
fact it functions basically as
coordinates for where to put your finger
so the way it worked is there are six
lines representing the strings
and then depending on which type of
tablet you're using there's either
numbers or letters which tell you which
fret to play
so for example if you're on the highest
line which is the first string
if it said zero that would mean play the
open string
if it says one play the first fret two
three four all the way up the neck very
easy there's another system
uh where you use letters instead so a b
c
d e so a is open b c d
e f the letter system is uh referred to
as french tablature
and the numbers are italian tab
be careful when reading italian tab
though because the lines are flipped
around
in orientation i personally love to play
from tablature
and especially from facsimiles you know
the
pictures of the manuscripts from the
16th century
it's such a beautiful aesthetic
experience and
also some loot books like the italian
capirola
loot book from 1520 are actually adorned
with
beautiful paintings apparently that
specific loot book
was covered in these really elaborate
paintings around
the perimeter of the tab to ensure its
survival
and it worked compared to
our modern classical guitar loots can
seem
rather small lightweight and
with very low tension strings
for me the sound difference is mainly
that the loot
can seem soft uh very intimate
but actually i think it has a magical
soft silvery sound that really is
what the charm of the loot is all about
you'll also notice that loots generally
have a beautifully decorated
sound hole which we call a rose which is
a pattern very intricate pattern carved
directly into
the wood and it's just purely aesthetic
as far as i know it serves
no acoustic purpose just it's just
beautiful
besides that it still has its teardrop
shape just like the ood the bowl back
this instrument has a particularly
beautiful
back made of flamed maple wood and
these are individual strips of wood we
call ribs that are heated up
and bent into shape and then they're
they're glued together
the loot in its day was considered quite
the versatile instrument
and in fact because it was so popular
throughout europe it was used for a wide
array
of musical styles very much like the
guitar today
the loot was used to play in ensembles
for dance music
it could be used as a really ideal
instrument to accompany
a voice or many voices and it has one of
the largest
solar repertoires of any instrument
so to hear the loot in action let's
listen to how it sounds when it
accompanies the voice
versus when it plays solo and to do that
we can listen to
some music by john dowland one of the
most renowned
loot composers and virtuoso lutenists of
his day
downland often set the same piece in
many versions
and in fact in his manuscript you can
see printed
next to each other you have a version
for just four voices
and then you have a version for loot and
one voice
and in another version he often
published those same pieces
but in a solo loot version so he was
totally okay adapting his pieces
uh many times so let's listen to one of
those pieces
this is now oh now i needs must part by
john dowland sung by
soprano caitlyn foley
no
[Music]
it's
[Music]
and here is darwin's version of the same
song but for
solo loot which in this case he retitles
the frog galliard
[Music]
so
[Music]
let's listen to one more example this is
a very melancholic text by john dowland
flow my tears which is perhaps his most
famous piece
first with voice
my
again
[Music]
lord let me
[Music]
and now for the solo loot version which
he calls the la creme pavone
[Music]
now as you heard these solo loot
versions
had a lot of extra notes right
these were embellishments on the
original
tune and basically loot players at the
time would be able to improvise
this sort of ornamentation
on an original tune and they used this
technique called
division playing where they would
elaborate on the
the melody so for example if you saw a
simple melody like this
that could become or
or maybe even there's
infinite possibilities and it seems from
the treatises
that this was a very common practice and
often people write
that to play gracefully you are meant to
add
a lot of embellishments a lot of
ornaments to the music which means that
the piece that you have is really
shorthand
and you are meant to take part in the
act of composition itself
by adding more music as i mentioned
earlier
the solar repertoire for the loot is
vast
besides dance movements like galliards
and pavans
you have intabulations or arrangements
of vocal works so any uh acapella
piece for say for four voices could
become a
solo loot piece which means that there
are just
endless you know chances for the loot to
play
solo music besides that two other types
of
songs which were very common were
fantasias and
richer cars these were very contrapuntal
pieces maybe very virtuosic using a lot
of
imitation so to finish our introduction
to
the loot and his music let's listen to a
richer car
by francesco de milano who was so
influential and well regarded that he
was referred to as
il divino or the divine one
[Music]
thanks so much for watching please do
subscribe if you haven't already
and check out my patreon if you want to
support
this channel see you next time
[Music]
you